for more on Border funding we're joined
Now by Republican congresswoman from
North Carolina and oversight and
accountability Committee Member Virginia
Fox congresswoman Merry Christmas to you
early let's dig right in because you
guys have gone home the house for a uh
holiday break the Senate still holding
on on possible talks we know secretary
myus up on the hill where do you see
things standing uh with regards to a
possible border deal in exchange for
Ukraine funding
well this border deal should have been
done a long time ago Griff we passed hr2
soon after we uh opened the session uh
early this year the hr2 has been in the
Senate they have dallied around till the
polls are telling them that this is a
serious issue for the president when
you've got fedman and Cinema uh talking
about it even Katie Hobs who said that
the Border wasn't an issue during her
campaign and now they are it's it's
something that we have to deal with the
American people are sick and tired of
what uh President Biden has done what
president mayor what uh secretary
mayorcas has done they both should be
impeached for doing this uh particularly
mayorcas because he's been carrying out
the orders of the president but we're
going down that road and that we need to
do something about the border and we
should have done it a long time ago when
President Trump was in office he had the
strongest border policies we've ever had
we need to go back to those policies
congresswoman we're looking live now at
Eagle Pass Texas the border patrol
processing the migrants there under the
Port of Entry I've just spent the last
seven days reporting there I understand
from my sources uh this morning they've
had at least three Chinese uh migrants
Crossing there the entirety of the week
there were more than
15,000 congresswoman the week before
more than 177,000 in just this one Del
Rio sector Eagle pass's total population
is only 30,000 they're getting the
entire population Crossing every two
weeks there right now but yet your
colleague in the last hour Congressman
Glenn iy says that Republicans
yourselves are the ones to blame for
inaction listen
here they can't resolve issues with
respect respect to the issues we were
just talking about so you know you got
the house Republican leadership pulling
bills off the floor and you got people
like Congressman chip Roy going on the
floor to complain about the inability of
the house Republican leadership to get
things done that's a big part of the
problem congresswoman do you own some of
the blame we absolutely do not again hr2
was passed and sent to the Senate it's
the Democrats who won't do it Griff
you've seen this you've been around a
long time the the Democrats project onto
Republicans what their problems are they
refuse to uh seal the Border we need
president Trump back in office when he
was in office we did not have these
problems and I'm endorsing his return to
the presidency so that we can solve this
with Republicans in office it is the
Senate the Democrats in the Senate the
Democrats in the house we passed hr2 no
Democrats supported that we need to
close that border down we need in our
funding bill we had money for additional
border patrol not to be babysitters not
to be a welcoming party but to bring uh
but to stop people from coming in we
need to continue building the wall we
need all of President Trump's policies
back in place and we need to stop this
President Biden uh revers the policies
on his first day in office we need
President Biden gone we can't take four
more years of this grip we have got to
have president Trump back in office and
and the border patrol agents that I have
spent so much of my time covering they
can't take much more they need something
done right now I want to just change
gears before we run out of time
congresswoman because I want to update I
want your Insight on where the house
investigation into this widespread
raging anti-Semitism on college campus
college campuses is what's being done
about it what can we
expect well we have launched an invest
tigation into the anti-Semitism that
exists on campus and we will follow that
investigation wherever it leads us it
may C cause us to bring in presidents
again we don't know we will have people
devoted specifically to doing these
investigations it's not just going to be
uh the campuses that we brought in
before Harvard MIT and upen but campuses
all over the country we intend to stop
this r anti rampant anti-Semitism on the
campuses Griff and do you believe that
it is a violation of these students uh
rights to to for particularly the Jewish
students on these campuses to not be
provided safety to not be assured
confidence that they won't be both
intimidated and or
uh physically even uh
attacked oh absolutely it's a violation
of their rights our number one right in
the constitution is our right to
religion our second right is the right
to free speech these students have a
right to practice their religion to be
Jewish and to not hide their uh
jewishness or to hide their faith and
this is wrong what's happened on these
campuses and the number one role of the
president is safety of the students
there and they need to be paying closer
attention into that Griff congresswoman
Virginia Fox thank you for your time and
insight have a merry Christmas you too
Griff hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now